I emphasize that
soldiers
on military service do not and will not participate in hostilities and there will
be no additional call-up of
reservists from the reserve. The
assigned tasks are solved only by
professional military men.
I am sure they will reliably ensure
security and peace for the people of Russia.
I want to turn to mothers John,
sisters, brides and girlfriends.  our soldiers
and officers who are now in battle
defending Russia go to a special
military operation
I understand how you worry about your
loved ones and loved ones
you can be proud of them just as the whole country is
proud of them and is worried about them together with you